Oh
ala casa te aviso oubliez wat po ou votre
def leppard non plus
et étant très haut peut-on voir comme la
source lunaire ou quelque chose pourrait être
tout un peu ouais le
concours juste parce que nous y allons Marjorie non je
devrais avoir chaud
c'est un non à  notre hélicoptère 5 830
whisky et voir l'usine à chiots 5802
whisky sinistre bénisse généralement fournir
devrions-nous simplement aller au sang à travers tout
cela oui ouais
ce serait bien de voir qu'il y a comme si
c'était un peu ondulé qu'ils ont été dans
le droit  la couche de gloire en ce moment ouais d'
accord ouais regarde ça en bas je
dois considérer que ce n'est
pas avec la rue les maisons tu connais
la rivière donc Dovie ne me dis pas que c'est ça
tu ne veux pas la grande route non ok
donc là-bas je veux le  bien en dessous de
la maison ok comme ça ouais je ne veux pas de
cette merde oh ici mais en sortira
shanna hélicoptère merde oh ça a été une
ville de sedona où nous devons aimer Blue
Meadows quand je t'amène à la bonne
chose bien dans le  Sun
Justin à six echo quelle est ta
destination  ion j'appelle ça un séjour de 36 secondes au printemps,
il est la ligne médiane de
je suis juste à environ trois miles de la
circulation
voir ils aimeraient le petit bout de
maisons et il y a une herbe pour vous savez
ouais
comment faire être de cette façon
notre  l'hélicoptère 02 est que nous sommes à environ cinq à
l'embouchure sud-ouest toujours en train de tirer
capture au whisky bonnes réponses quand
vous êtes en train de rebondir vers lui
maintenant ce sont les petites maisons juste à
travers ici beaucoup de jeux en Amérique du Nord sont
allés tuer Yankee gardez votre visage
jambe  à l'intérieur d'une Lincoln, courez mon 35 à droite mais
pour l'option, faites un rocher rond fermé à gauche
mais il a été dans mon cœur pour
vous coûter de la propriété pour faire
le [ __ ] d'article c'est ce qu'il faut faire
au Mali salami favela téléphone
qu'en est-il de sortir  maintenant très haut, donc
nous obtenons la disposition des maisons dont
nous serions d'accord pour souffrir, mais
c'est un corps différent
terrifiant Papa vent tout maintenant 3607 faire en
sorte qu'il soit juste en bas de Linnell Row pourrait
répondre à droite panne d'
accord le diable exact OHS trafic trois
miles  au sud-ouest de vous à 8 500 tourné
vers le nord, un changement de fréquence cessna
vous a approuvé alors
ok je suppose que c'est suffisant pour
distribuer le tir
ouais d'
accord Sturm 585 fait plus tôt juste en bas
de moi d'accord nous pouvons aller faire une partie du
vol 12 en Amérique du Nord tuant un
rôle clé dans 35 droits à  le terrain 136 ou 11
règle Rogers et 35 à droite merci
tout ce terrain était un grand ranch ouais et
il y a le siège du ranch
là-bas hein et un animal noble non et
c'est une grande fille c'est le grand Cayenne à
droite un peu de trucs marrants le  en train de faire une
non-présentation pour vous Chester 550 hors de mon
Terry continu Justin zéro du
micro sans la croix de jambe de i-35
juste sur 16 exécuteur seulement 35
notre thérapie par hélicoptère avec le concessionnaire
entrant maintenant est-il des
écumes vous êtes trop risqué  Je signale un demi-
mile à l'ouest d'ici quand 3606
puissances de X 1 X 1
maintenant 494 lemme Centennial terram quart de
mile au sud la température du rail de l'aéroport
quel est ton nom exactement j'aime avec
Ivan
75 pouces pop tout le troisième nord-américain
juste étoile  ting la base gauche maintenant juste
au-dessus du lien dans un i-25 electric direct
midland right turtleman
Justin 0 ou je suppose que c'est un gastronomique
prudent quoi